Pride people are mad at them because
they didn't support Dylan Mulvaney so
they like kicked it out you don't win
you know either way at the end of the
day but I think about the companies that
own these companies the people that own
these companies and why would they
let a decision like that take the
company down I don't think they thought
it was going to I think this is a
legitimate public outrage one where they
just push too far and people and
you and it wasn't even like a real like
promotion so why Target do the same
thing well I think that's an ESG thing
that's an ESG thing right and Target
lost billions of dollars too because
people people are sick of this
they're sick of social things like that
that are controversial getting stuffed
into your face and we you have to accept
it yeah and people are like I don't want
to accept it by the way the two
Executives in charge of the campaign
have been fired